in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Roger
and amber are here hey guys how are you
hey Dave welcome are you from just up
the road in clarksville tennessee very
fun here to do your debt-free scream
absolutely and how much have you paid
off paid off $85,000 very cool and how
long did that take about three years
good making what kind of money well when
we started out we were the twenty one
mark and then uh at the twenty one
thousand correct okay I had just gotten
out of the military little things and I
was in the job market mhm and then um
income went up to forty to a year mm-hm
and ironically sadly enough I actually
just lost my job as soon as we paid off
our debt so oh my goodness it's a
negative thing but at the same time it's
positive get right back up on the horse
and start chipping away at her
retirement fund now absolutely Wow
oh very cool as soon as you land
something new and so amber do you work
outside the home I don't know okay
alright and what kind of debt was the
eighty five thousand it was a little bit
of everything really we had a car well
sever a couple of cars we had a student
loan medical debt credit cards yeah well
you paid off more than you made during
this time so you must have sold
something sold a car and our very last
day we were fortunate enough I don't say
fortunate enough cuz it was a huge loss
to receive an inheritance oh why sure
dad chipped away our last little bit of
day and how much was the inheritance the
inheritance came from her father yeah
how much there's just a lot of family
involved so we'd rather not say okay
that's fair and how much was the car
that's sold I sold my car for six fifty
three hundred dollars okay all right and
so the inheritance had to be at least
decent because they're otherwise these
numbers just don't work
absolutely okay cuz I mean again you
made about twenty to thirty thousand to
forty thousand dollars a year for three
years okay all right cool very cool
well what started you on this journey
tell me about it well how'd you decide
to get out of debt what happened I've
listened to Joe to the show for several
years
and when we got married and there was a
lot of debt that both of us had and we
said you know what we need to straighten
things out and we as soon as her
daughter Lucy was born we focused and
said you know what it's time yeah so
cool and so amber whose idea was this to
get started on this year's or Rogers it
was really both of ours
but yeah it's kind of started with him
and then we got on board and okay so
how's it feel to be out of that um it's
still adapting do it well and when you
get another job it's gonna be a lot
doing it doesn't mean my gosh if you'd
have 85,000 hours where the debt lost
your job you'd really be up a creek
exactly the good news is that you're
clear at least and now you got to just
worry about is get the wolf away from
the door and keep the food on the table
and that kind of stuff and you can do
that yeah very cool well congratulations
guys I'm proud for you well thank you
thank you and we're proud that you did
this Congrats and thanks for you for
your thank you for your service as well
excellent all right Roger and amber from
Clarksville Tennessee $85,000 paid off
in three years making 21 to 42 a year
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two
alright ago you guys absolutely fabulous